welcome my name is ini zhao i am an
assistant professor at the johns hopkins
university department of biostatistics
and it's my pleasure today to come here
and share some of my work with a group
of people who work on microbiology
i generally develop statistical methods
for analyzing microbiome data and today
i'm going to talk about a log linear
model for inferences on bias in
microbial sequencing studies this is a
joint work with me myself and dr green
center from emory university
so uh i think it doesn't require me to
say much about the importance about
the microbiome
in human health and
how it relates to our everyday life
so now many large studies routinely
collect the data
on the bacterial communities in our
bodies such as god and skin and aura
so generally speaking the way
to measure these microbial abundances
usually looks like this we use
sequencing method to do it so that
we use a sequencing method so that we
can
instead of having to culture the
different bacterial species we can have
the radicants for thousands of bacterial
species at the same time the general
workflow is like this so we first
isolate the dna from the tissues
extracting the dna and then those dnase
are subject to sequencing
then there are generally two ways to
sequence the
the bacterial dnase but those are not
important but after all at the end of
the day what we get
is a big table where generally speaking
each of the raw represent a sample and
each of the columns represents one
different bacterial species then we can
use this table which characterized by
microbiome community in the sample that
you collect to do many things such as we
may want to associate to see whether the
microbiome community is related to human
health maybe it's
important for treatment or maybe we can
use it for prediction
so uh
in the sequencing studies uh
bias is something that we cannot go
around bias is the ub creators in
microbial sequencing it is it is well
spreading all types of high dimensional
genomic sequences
bias is defined as a systematic
distortion of the measurement from the
true values so what you see from your
sequencer is different from what the
true relative abundances of the
bacterial species in the community
recently there was this high profile
paper which characterized and tried to
correct for the bias in metagenomic
sequencing experiments
so generally what does it observe
we call this model as the mwc model
based on the three initials of the three
authors
the general conclusion from this model
from the experiment was that
the bias
is a multiplicative factor that works on
the different bacterial relative
abundances so generally speaking
this is a toy example where there are
only three bacterial species that are in
the community suppose you have them each
of them constitute one third of
the system
then during each of the steps in the
experimental protocol you do the dna
extraction you do the tci you do the
sequencing each of the steps has a
multiplicative factor on the bias of the
two relative abundances and at the end
of the day what you observe is a
distorted version of the relative
abundances that are in the community
so what this multiplicity bias would
mean to us with respect to analysis
one of the things that we can
immediately realize was that because of
the multicollective bias
we may sometimes
the data that we receive we
may direct us to a different conclusion
than what the truth it is
and this is true even when the all the
bacteria
even when all the
samples were processed in the same way
and all the samples have a same bias
factor so this is also a toy example
from their mwc paper
that suppose you have two samples sample
one and a sample two that have three
bacteria species
that sample 3 has reduced the relative
abundance
in the true community but because of the
bias factor that are the same across the
two studies
across the two experiments
you um
you see actually an increased relative
abundance in the observed data well in
the true data there's actually a
reduction in the relative abundances of
tax on three
so this is problematic because
generally speaking
most of the statistical methods that
people use for analyzing microbiome data
assumes that the bias can cancel out if
all your samples were processed exactly
in the same way
well it is not a tool based on the
enzyme model
so what we intended to do
was
the mwc model is very inductive but
there are still some problems with it so
what we want to do is we want to try to
evaluate whether this mwc model
works fine in our data set and to what
extent this is a
correct so the mwc model if we write it
in a mathematical formula it generally
looks like this um
where um there's a little bit of a
notation change when i convert my pdf
file to the powerpoint but generally
speaking here the p
is the true relative abundance of
attacks on j
in the community and a p2 is the
observed relative violence in the
community
and the multiplicative factor generally
says that okay
my observed relative abundance
is a true relative abundance multiplying
some factor where
this exponential is just a for
mathematical convenience but this is a
much collective factor of course you
have to standardize it somehow where the
denominator is the summation of the
numerator across all the j's where the j
is the total number of bacterial species
in the community
so m dynamic model is a multiplicative
model it's also a deterministic model
that it says your p tilde is a
multiplicative change of your p
generally speaking that physicians do
lack do not lack deterministic models
because we think there will always be
randomness in the system and we want to
characterize this randomness to see how
well the data with randomness will fit
into this deterministic model
the second implication from the mbc
model was that the bias factor of one
taxa is not impacted by other taxon in
the community
this is important because this allows us
to model the bias one text at a time
instead of having to
think about the interactions between the
whole communities but there's also a
question mark because the mwc paper did
not really test on whether this
assumption is true whether another taxa
may impact the bias of this one
the third
observation from the mwc model was that
the bias depends on both the
experimental procedures as well as
bacterial properties so one taxon may
have a low rise factor using one dna
extraction protocol but it may have a
high bias factor using a different
extraction protocol and reversely in the
same extraction protocol one taxon may
have a high bias factor another taxon
may have a low bias factor depending on
the characteristics of the taxa which we
think makes real sense because the taxon
may have different like
cell characteristics such as whether
they are gram negatives or gram
positives
and the final point was that the
normalization factor depends on the true
relative to prevalence of the bias
factors of all texts in the sample and
we don't have any issue with that
the purpose of this study is really to
try to say okay if we think about
the random noise in the data
and we want to test whether there's real
interactions between taxon and taxa with
respect with respect to bias
so the data catastrophe we use is from
the brooks data from paul brooks this is
a mock community with seven taxons this
is a fairly large sample um some
fairly large data sets that have 240
samples with the 58 combinations of
bacteria so essentially they have seven
different bacterias that mix with
different proportions where the
proportions are known so that we know
the true relative abundances and
therefore we will be able to model the
biases
the samples were processed in six states
through three different ways
where we named it as cells dna and pcr
product this is where
from which product the samples were
processed
and the little table tells how many of
the samples have only one hexa how many
samples have two tensor and how many
examples have all seven of the taxons in
the sample
so our research questions are like do
the place have different advice between
them do the different place have a very
different effect
and also we want to ask whether one
taxer impacts the bias of another taxa
of course we know the data are presented
in a way that there are many meetings
because that
many of the species are not present
in certain samples because of the design
so um
the model setup um
i generally like this so we have an otu
table or an aes v table essentially this
is a species table where each of the raw
is a sampling each of the column major
species there are n rows and the j
columns where the p and the p two that
are the true and the observed relative
abundances of taxon j in sample i
and i have we have an indicator
derivative to indicate whether delta g
is present in sample i
it is one if it is present and it is
zero otherwise
of course we assume that
all the relative abundances in that
sample sum up to one no matter in the
true relative abundances or in the
observative relative of analysis so this
is just the protection technology
and we extend the mwc model so you see
everything on the right side is exactly
the same as the original mwc model the
only difference was that we put p tilde
which is observe the relative abundances
we replace data instead of the expected
values so that we know okay there is
randomness in this equation and we only
uh say on average your observed relative
abundances is that multiplicative effect
on the true relative combinances
okay
this
extend data
model not determine model with noise can
also be revisited in something like
in the log linear model where
essentially the log of the p tilde
equals the log of the true relative
abundances plus beta
j
that is a spice indicator for each of
the individual taxa then there's an
effect for alpha i which represents the
um which represents the samples and this
is from the common denominator from the
previous model and there's an epsilon
where
when i do the conversion that epsilon
disappears but there's a plus epsilon ig
we further extend the model to allow for
other characteristics which are the x
eyes over here in the model to be
characterized such as
the the x i generally represent
um how
in what protocol the samples were
processed such as in which
batch or in which plate the samples were
processed
so for estimation this model is overly
parameterized
there can be
so
as later i will show using real examples
you will be able to see that that we may
be able to have multiple
combinations of data that provide the
same equally well faded to the to the
data that we have
they will have like
the same different different parameters
that give you the same um that'll give
you the same model phase
but for estimation what we intended to
do is that we intended to get one set of
best estimators among the infinitely
many
parameter estimators
well
we will be able to do hypothesis testing
where when we properly set up the
hypothesis testing even though our beta
are not identifiable we will still be
able to test for
those those hypothesis meaning that we
will be able to ask many interesting
questions
so uh what we observe is that if we read
multiply
our
equations
by a compositional projection operator
which is essentially the um
diagonal matrix of the data which is the
indicator about whether or not that
attacks are present in the sample minus
one over n i will announce the number of
taxon present in the sample
times the inner product of delta i
transpose in the data i
this will eliminate anything that is
constant in i and we no longer help to
estimate our alpha i and the final model
looks like something like this where the
y id is a transformative version of the
observed relative abundance and the
difference between the log observed
relative abundance and the log true
relative abundance
times this
composition of projection operators
and the e
is
the original epsilon times this
compositional projection operator as
well
what we do is that we use something like
a vector trick essentially the general
idea is that our y
y ig is a single number but if you look
at it all together your y together is an
n by t matrix
and all the operations is on the matrix
form
what we do is that we stretch out all
our y's for essentially we stack the
first columns of second columns of y
after the first column the y and the
third columns of y and do this and we
can transform this into we call this as
a vector trig for estimation
so that what we estimate is a vector
value of this beta matrix and we can
once we get this vectored vectorized of
this beta matrix we can convert it back
to the original beta in the matrix form
uh there is some like a chronic product
and some mathematical uh relationships
that are needed but those are not really
important
the importance was that by using this
vector trick we will be able to run the
estimation very simply using these
squares
um i can give some examples
to really show why the model is over
parameterized so suppose we have two
plates
our x will be two
indicators if the sample was processed
in plate one it will be one in the first
column and if it is processed in column
if that page two it will be one on the
second column
then our beta will be a two by j matrix
where j is the total number of species
in the brooks data that is status
what we see is that if we add a constant
to the rows
meaning that because the bias is
multiplicative if we add a constant
which means we multiply the relative
abundances of all of all species in that
sample by a constant
then the relative abundances do not
change at all because once you do the
standardization that it disappears
so this gives y
uh the model that we have is overly
parameterize the model you add a
constant
uh the model phase will be exactly the
same
so another example is that suppose we
are interested in testing the
interactions
um
then the
x matrix will have an intercept then you
have a dirty matrix which essentially
represents whether
taxon1 is present in sample one or text
from one two is present in sample one
and your base matrix will look like this
where the first rows represent the main
effect and in the below
it represents interactions where the of
the the diagonals on the below j by j
matrix are the uh
are zeros because uh
because the may effect is already in the
first row
we can also use an alternative way to
specify this model where we remove the
intercepts of ones and only keep
the indicators about whether or not that
exam that species is present those
adaptable elements will represent the
may effect again we see if we add a
constant in each of the row it doesn't
change any of the bias if we add a value
if we add a value to the diagonal
element it will not
change its interaction
at all which also says that we have over
parameterize the model
so uh for even though our model is a
overly parameterized but we can
inference in the formatting like this
where we have c as a context matrix
where we have the vector of a of theta
and we can test whether this one is zero
and in most of the context we can write
this one as c beta q
where the q accounts for the
non-identifiability in the beta matrix
so i'll give an example uh
so for example suppose we have a three
taxa no covariance no bc data
then
our
beta will be our beta matrix is just the
beta 1 1 beta 1 2 and beta 1 3 the
vector rise of it will be like this as
well
suppose we want to ask whether there's a
any spot any any bias in this system
which essentially asks whether there's
whether the bias is different for tax on
one tax on two and a text of three
so your context matrix will look like
that like this so essentially this
negative one and a positive one says
that okay beta one negative one times
beta one plus
one times beta one two so essential
equals zero so that says beta one one
minus beta one two is zero the bottom is
between one one minus beta one three
equals zero when all three of them are
zero which means there's no bias because
again we know um adding a constant
doesn't change anything and if the three
of them are the same we can think about
them as all zeros
this is a
one example of that
another example uh suppose we have two
plates
as of before everyone would have whether
the bias factors differ between the
plates which essentially says beta one j
matters of
beta 1 g minus beta 1 j prime sorry this
is 1 j prime
equals beta 1 2 j minus beta 2 j prime
so essentially the difference between
the two rows in each of the columns are
the same
this will be for
for the main effect model
and if we go on to even more complex
models such as when we want interactions
such as in the broke data
so possibly want to know whether text on
j
impacts the bias factors of other taxa
that is to ask whether beta j k
equals beta j k prime
uh where uh
k is not equal to k prime which is not
equal to j
so suppose we want to know whether beta
y impacts the bias factor of other taxa
which essentially talks about whether
beta 1 2 equals beta 1 3 equals beta 1 j
and for the brooks data this will be a 5
division freedom test and there are some
other examples for this as well as one
test whether there's any interaction
between the text out which is to test
whether beta j k equals beta j k prime
for uh
all j
k and k prime with seven hexane in the
briggs data and this entails a 35
degrees of freedom test which
essentially says that we have 35
equations that we want to test
for this system
so uh the inverse that we do
we propose to do a um
f statistics
which is a very simple to understand so
essentially what we do is that
we can calculate the residuals
um under the null model and we can also
calculate the residuals from the
full model the full model is just the
model that we previously uh presented i
presently presented there the normal
model would be the model with the
constraint that a certain of the betas
have to be the same or certain functions
of the beta has to be the same
so
what we get is that we can get the
residuals from this model
and
we want to see whether the data uh
whether the models fit the data
similarly if your model saves fixes the
data similarly then your residuals
should be similar and your residual sum
of squares should also be simpler
so essentially the smaller the f
statistic says the the smaller
differences between your non-model
and your full model which also says that
the full model is not any different from
the non-model and we would prefer the
normal model because we can use
we can put more structure into the data
and it models the data as good as when
we put when we allow for more
flexibility
so the f statistic is just the residual
sum of squares under the null model
minus the residual sum of squares over
the full model
divided by the residual sum of squares
over the full model where
it's just a function from all the
residuals
the null distribution of this ad
statistics is hard to quantify because
of all the missing data and everything
in our data so we decided to do a
permutation approach
and we use a decorrelated residuals
because our residuals are
correlated with that naive permutation
doesn't work very well
but these are also like technical
details which i'm not going into too
much
so i just want to say
how the model
uh face
the the specific data
so here
the first analysis that we did was that
i hope you can see this this is a little
blurred in my screen uh generally uh
what we want to see is that we the first
model we test is that
whether
we the first slide gives a model
estimation with no interaction so
essentially we have seven different
bacterial species and a sixth place
we see
the beta estimate again this is only one
representation of all the possible bases
that will give us the equal phase
of the model
but what we see was that that the plate
1 and plate 2 have a similar beta
estimate 3 and four have similar
estimated four five and six have the
similar estimate
and when we plot them in the principle
component analysis so essentially you
can think about
uh
num plates that are closer together are
more similar with respect to their beta
estimator and we do see that plate 1 and
plate 2 are similar places 3 3 and plane
4 are similar
plates 5 and 6 are similar
so we looked back
we initially did not know why this is
the case and we looked back to the
original data and asked the person who
generated this data that it turned out
that place one and the two were
processed in the same way again remember
we have the cell samples the dna samples
and the pcr product samples
which
our estimated clusters naturally with a
different
place
and we do a hypothesis testing each of
the plates have a different bias factor
with the rest of the place
except i think only player
5 and 6 are not differentially
have are not different with respect to
their buyer's profile
the second task that we do was that we
try to test for the interactions
um
so the first model that we do is that we
apply our interaction model to all the
data
well at adjusting for the plate effect
you see that here we give the p values
from
10 000 the permutations that there's no
significant interaction effects here
so this is a
this actually supports what mwc model
initially uh proposed that the
interaction effect
probably is um is not as significant as
important as a may effect model when we
look at the specific place place one and
a two three and a four five and a six
which has a place of the same tag
and we sometimes do see
we do see significant differences in
place one and a two which are the place
where the main effects are the smallest
the main effects difference are the
smallest
where uh the places three four five and
six um there's
generally no significant difference with
respect to their bias provides we also
do hypothesis testing and we found was
that the interaction in fact even when
it was present such as in phase one and
the two the interaction effect was much
smaller in the mathematician compared to
the may effects model and this is we
were quite happy to see this result
because
um this essentially says that we may be
able to characterize the complex bias
generation process using something that
is that is simple
so um so finally use the final two
minutes as a discussion
currently this model only works for mock
communities when we have known relative
abundances because we need
to know
the differences between what you
observed and the true relative
abundances some ongoing work is
is carried on in our lab which uh in
which we try to
extend this model to situations in which
uh we do not know the true relative of
binances of course that will require
additional assumptions on the model
statistically we propose a multivariate
permutation with
when we have structure missing and this
can be uh have a general
applicability to other statistical
contexts
what do we think is the most important
was that um the fact that there's very
little interaction or there's no
interactions between the
bi between the biases between taxon and
opens the doors to many future analysis
for example we may be able to design
models that are bias resistant because
of the lack of interactions in the bias
generation process
and finally i want to thank my
collaborator glenn sentence
in
doing a lot of this work and
we
we worked together on this project
and
he's a person who obtained the brooks
data
we also want to thank
michael maclan and benjamin kanaha
who are the major authors on the mwc
paper
for nice discussions and critics for our
paper and finally we want to thank
paul brooks for providing the data and i
want to thank our funding sources from
nh as well